so this simple thing people have not
handled from their childhood so when you
don't handle this one thing everything
will be wrong everything will be
accidental
so what do you say to someone maybe
they're 30 years old and they've had
this life of
mistakes and
regret and maybe alcoholism or gambling
or some other problems but they want to
be conscious they want to be blissful
they want to be enlightened they want to
be a happy person filled with love what
path do they take
right now there is one little screw here
in this furniture i will ask you you're
a strong guy i will ask you to unscrew
this with your hands can't do it you do
it you may lose all your nails i'll
allow you to use your teeth maybe you
lose some of them it's gonna be a
problem but it'll be right there
but if i give you a screwdriver boom do
it easy in a minute you will get it out
so this is the power of the tool yeah so
as there are tools for doing things in
the external world there are tools to
handle this what are those tools
this is all very like mystic
difficult for people to grasp there are
there are mystical aspects also but that
is not for everybody but i mean in this
conversation only for those who are
interested in those things who want to
pursue that aspect for the rest of the
people for somebody if their back back
goes away his life changes for somebody
if his headache goes away his life
changes yes somebody drops his alcohol
consumption addiction his life changes
somebody some compulsive thought that
drives him crazy that goes away these
are simple things this is just a small
screwdriver is all he needs he doesn't
need a total overhaul
mysticism is a different aspect it is
like you're not just interested in
living well you want to know the very
root of life yes that's a different
aspect that's not for everybody that is
only for those who seek that but for
common people all they want to do is
they want to live peacefully joyfully
with some sense of purpose to whatever
they're doing in their lives
today
we've come to this place where
if you want to be peaceful you need a
chemical
you want to be joyful you need a
chemical you want to be healthful you
need a chemical
well you want to be ecstatic of course
there is a chemical right
so what is the consequence of this why
this is happening
one thing is in this generation one
thing that's happened in people's minds
is the heaven has collapsed in people's
minds see uh i've been talking to people
50 years ago if i spoke to people
and i asked how many of you want to go
to heaven almost 80 would raise their
hands
today you go to your university and ask
them how many of you want to go to
heaven
they'll say
they think it's a ridiculous question
all right nobody will raise their hand
so in their minds heaven is collapsed
there's no place to go
so they want to do everything here all
right
so they have not found how to be
joyful and ecstatic within themselves
if you do not raise human consciousness
if you do not teach people how to sit
here
feeling absolutely blissed out within
yourself by your own nature because
this human mechanism is the most
sophisticated chemical factory
if you are a good co
you would produce the chemicals that
will give you fantastic experience
if you're a lousy ceo you're giving
yourself a bad experience
yes now you're buying chemicals from
outside to fix that all right so
essentially you're a bad manager of your
own system you're not taking charge of
this why is that happen because your
education your society is talking about
conquering the world but never taught
you anything about how to take charge of
this there's so much technology here in
this room the most complex and
sophisticated technology is
within your system
heaven has collapsed in people's minds
which is a good thing because it's a
good thing it is because the idea
that this is not the place to live well
there is another place where you will
live well it's a wrong idea right
this is the place to live well you can
have heaven right here yes
and uh who told you you're not already
in heaven and making a mess out of it
so in your mind this concept of heaven
relates to like a harmony amongst
yourself the in the people the living
things around you including the soil see
essentially it's like this
so to create pleasantness in the
surroundings
we need the cooperation of people and
forces around us
without everybody's cooperation you
can't create a pleasant atmosphere but
pleasantness of the body pleasantness of
the mind pleasantness of emotion and
energy is 100 your business
isn't it
what happens in your mind your emotion
your chemistry your energies must be
your way isn't it it well it's yours yes
it is so it must be your way but it's
not happening your way right now because
it's in a compulsive reactive state
anybody can cause anything within you so
if i decide what clothes you must wear
what food you must eat what you should
do every day you will call this slavery
isn't it
right now someone else something else
can decide what happens within you isn't
this the most horrible form of slavery
that someone can decide whether you're
happy or unhappy
yeah that's not good that's not that's
not the best so the problem is just this
an intelligence which needs to be
conscious
is unfortunately unconscious and
compulsive
so the only problem that you have is
compulsive reaction to life around you
what is needed is a conscious response
to life
so this simple thing people have not
handled from their childhood
right so when you don't handle this one
thing everything will be wrong
everything will be accidental your
success and failure both are accidental
why is it though human beings are not
the strongest creatures on the planet
compared to other species
why is it that human beings are
dominating this world
simply because of our ability to use
tools isn't it
and our intellect our ability to
manipulate our environment yes but even
then if we didn't have
knowledge of using tools right
the buffalos would have mowed us down
all right there are tools for doing
things in the external world there are
tools to handle this because you don't
have a tool kit
this machine which is the most complex
machine is going crazy you just use the
tools don't worry about the philosophy
don't worry about belief system don't
worry about your concept somebody's
concepts your beliefs somebody's beliefs
just use the necessary tools
being peaceful joyful loving is a
natural outcome of that
because the only reason is it has worked
what is it that's worked i did not teach
them a morality i did not teach them a
philosophy i did not promise them
miracles i did not pull
gold chains out of thin air and give it
to them no nothing simply tools to fix
themselves how to sit how to breathe how
to manage yourself this is all yes
our nose is located nice right above our
mouth
suppose you don't brush your teeth for
three days though this nose is right
here it won't tell you you have not
brushed your teeth
the whole room will know you have not
brushed your teeth but you will not know
this is the human predicament it's very
easy to see what's wrong with this guy
what's wrong with her what's wrong with
her
it takes a lot of observation to see
what's wrong with this
that
level of keenness of observation is
missing in most people they need to
cultivate that we are the most
comfortable generation ever in the
history of humanity no question about it
isn't it yes
we are super empowered because of the
science and technology
as there is a science and technology for
our external well-being there is a whole
science and technology for inner
well-being
unfortunately
most cultures have ignored this and
thinking that if you make all the
external arrangements well
everything will be okay
united states of america
is a huge statement that this is not how
it works
the most affluent country on the planet
70 of the population are supposed to be
on prescription medication so pain is a
good thing physically
because that is your
self-preservation mechanism
but suffering is something that you do
in your mind
so pain that happens in your body you
take it in your mind and multiply it a
thousand times or a million times
depending on how capable you are
or how stupid you are and suffer it a
million times over
right now
most human beings are like this what
happened
10 years ago they can still suffer
what may happen day after tomorrow they
already suffer
[Music]
they are not suffering life they think
they are suffering life they are
suffering the two most fantastic
faculties that human beings alone have
a vivid sense of memory and a fantastic
sense of imagination